bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo en compagnie
cette semaine de delphine gérard bonjour
delphine dans l'actualité cette semaine
c'est bien sûr le vote du mariage pour
tous qui a retenu notre attention à
l'assemblée épilogue parlementaire de
discussions sous haute tension
trois cent trente et une voix pour 225
contre et 10 abstentions les
parlementaires ump sont immédiatement
partis déposer un recours au conseil
constitutionnel le projet doit de
moralisation de la vie publique en
conseil des ministres le texte prévoit
notamment plus de transparence pour les
élus les parlementaires sont en majorité
d'accord sauf pour la publication de
leur patrimoine bataille d'amendements
ont vu lorsque le texte arrivera à
l'assemblée enfin le torchon brûle entre
les élus communistes et le gouvernement
en cause l'aministie syndicale qui avait
été voté au sénat cette semaine le
ministre alain vidalis a exprimé son
désaccord sur ce texte
dans la foulée la commission des lois de
l'assemblée la rejeter
les communistes sont furieux et là
encore le passage dans l'hémicycle
promet d'être chaud le 16 mai prochain
est avec nous pour commenter les temps
forts de cette semaine à munich le petit
bonjour bonjour réputé socialiste de
paris porte parole du groupe socialiste
à l'assemblée nationale
alors avant de dérouler ensemble
l'actualité c'est la tradition dans
cette émission on va écouter ce que
pensent de vous vos collègues députés
ils ont été interrogés par françois
flamand le député assidus très investi
sur le question notamment
qui touchent au logement et en plus
aujourd'hui une porte parole du groupe
socialiste et voilà je je travaille avec
elles en toute confiance
nous avons participé à de nombreuses
séances en commun j'ai l'impression que
c'est une adversaire plutôt rugueuse et
de ce que je peux en juger
voilà l m'a l'air convaincu
très à gauche donc c'est une vraie
adversaires c'est quelqu'un qui me
paraît en tout cas autant de puissants
jugé assez présente dans l'hémicycle
quelqu'un qui travaille quelqu'un qui
s'investit dans son mandat et ça je peux
le dire en toute honnêteté
elle défend ses convictions qui sont pas
les miennes il m'est déjà arrivé d'être
en opposition avec elle notamment sur le
débat européen
nous avons brettés amicalement mais
fermement
donc je lui conseille de continuer son
action de manière que je puisse m'y
opposer à elle c'est une femme que
j'apprécie énormément
elle a du caractère elle n'a pas sa
langue dans la poche et c'est une
militante hors pair j'aime beaucoup
annick j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à
travailler avec elle elle est toujours
souriante accueillante et disponible et
elle nous a permis au début pour nous
les nouveaux parents de parlementaires
d'être à guérir plus vite qu'eux on
pousse on pouvait l'être parce que avec
les petites astuces la connaissance
qu'elle a du parlement c'est toujours
utile
donc merci à nyc tout simplement alors à
la fois accueillante mais aussi rugueuse
convaincu sa coupe vous correspond ce
que vous avez entendu que de compliments
mais plutôt j'en suis moi je vais
revenir à la case l2 après sa cure chez
vous parce que j'ai jamais entendu
autant de compliments ça fait plaisir on
cherche on travaille pas on cherche les
détracteurs de ce quart est convaincu ce
sont les qualités d'un porte parole
oui on les qualités d'un porte parole
c'est justement d'essayer de résumer la
parole de tous c'est pas toujours facile
c'est pour ça que je plaide avec
d'autres pour le collectif et pour
éviter c'est vrai que chacun fasse
entendre sa petite musique
quelquefois c'est vrai avec raison sur
le fond mais d'autres fois pas toujours
donc être porte par porte parole c'est
justement plutôt d'être dans la dans la
recherche de la centale au fait si c'est
que toutes les semaines ou presque enfin
vous tourner mais c'est vous qui après
les réunions de groupe allait porter la
parole de ce qui s'est dit et c'est
sûrement pas toujours très sains la
partie heureusement le partager
cette fonction avec mon camarade thierry
mandon et on s'entend très bien tous les
deux mais en même temps nous étions
aussi tous les deux on va en parler au
séminaire de notre groupe les lions pour
qu'il y ait un travail en amont un peu
plus développé et on entendait eduardo
rien sippel vous avez formé les petits
jeunes et petits nouveaux il y en a eu
beaucoup
l'année dernière mais beaucoup beaucoup
de ben oui et non parce que je leur ai
expliqué c'est vrai qu'il qu'il se
tourner vers nous parce que il découvre
l assemblée nationale il faut du temps
pour la découvrir il faut du temps moi
qui est élu en 2002 nous étions peu
nombreux à gauche à être de nouveau
parlementaire en 2002 et personne ne m'a
aidé un dos que je me suis débrouillé
tout seul
donc c'est vrai pour un certain nombre
de choses bien sûr nous les avons aidés
gd pas la seule à le faire en revanche
ce que je leur ai dit et ce qu'ils
avaient du mal à comprendre c'est que
moi je vivais pour la première fois la
majorité
être député de la majorité je vous
garantis que ça n'a rien à voir avec est
réputé le plus difficile je l' ai connu
pendant dix ans l'opposition donc je
suis ravi et c'est ce que je souhaitais
j'ai tout fait pour être député dents
dans la majorité ça vous prend beaucoup
plus de temps et vous avez de fait
beaucoup plus de responsabilités et
notamment en termes de présence parce
que vous ne pouvez pas vous permettre
d'être minoritaire dans sur un projet
c'était de la majorité ça n'exclut pas
les états d'âme c'est ce qu'on va voir
tout de suite puisqu'on commence lundi
avec une petite séance de thérapie
collective
c'est une thérapie de groupe
effectivement qui se passe à l'assemblée
en ce lundi il s'agit de votre groupe de
députés socialistes jean marc ayrault
est venu dans l'après-midi à vous voir
pour entendre vos récriminations vos
griefs éventuellement vos compliments
message entendu a dit le premier
ministre en sortant de la séance
collective jean baptiste daoulas
ambiance de thérapie de groupe à
l'assemblée
la sphère cahuzac e1000 le moral des
députés socialistes
un groupe majoritaire qui a bien du mal
à trouver sa place
un an après l'élection de françois
hollande il faut sortir d'un rapport
entre le gouvernement et les
parlementaires où on aurait le choix que
d'être soi déloyaux soit godillots des
mois qui ont passé n'ont pas toujours
permis d'avoir une coopération optimum
entre le groupe socialiste et le
gouvernement les députés ne veulent plus
subir les textes de loi les bien-être
associés en amont à l'assemblée le
premier ministre a voulu les apaiser je
comprends bien ce que représente la
tâche de parlementaires c'est à dire à
la fois de voter la loi de soutenir le
gouvernement lorsqu'on est dans la
majorité aussi est en contact permanent
avec le terrain de faire le lien entre
les deux donc c'est ça que je suis venu
d'abord écouté et puis je dirais
quelques mots là à la fin de cette
réunion et je crois qu'elle aura été de
toute façon extrêmement utile aucune
décision concrète n'a été annoncée après
le séminaire mais les couacs ont aussi
été évité à la sortie même la turbulente
aile gauche est satisfaite de la méthode
même moi je m'attendais pas à ce que ce
soit aussi décomplexée en termes de
prise de parole et de franchise autre
revendication des députés socialistes
rencontrer régulièrement françois
hollande
le président avait pourtant juré qu'il
ne convoquerait jamais la majorité à
l'elysée mais la porte est entrouverte
les bus entiers qui arrive à l'elysée
pour soi des consignes c'est fini en
revanche le fait de pouvoir recevoir par
petits groupes les parlementaires c'est
ce que tout le monde souhaite c'est déjà
ce qu'ils font en attendant françois
hollande les députés socialistes
recevront
jean marc ayrault et harlem désir dès ce
mardi en réunion de groupe
au programme la politique économique de
la majorité alors annick lepetit vous
occupiez du groupe de travail intitulé
la vie parlementaire et vous avez eu la
lourde tâche de rassembler les griefs
pour les porter au premier ministre
alors c'était quoi sa grille et oui
enfin c'était pas une lourde tâche
c'était c'était un travail nécessaire en
fait parce que là nous avions eu un
travail collectif en atelier toute la
matinée et donc par exemple pour ce qui
concerne mon atelier il y avait à peu
près une centaine de députés qu'on a qui
étaient présents par par petits groupes
et puis à peu près une cinquantaine qui
se sont exprimés donc quand j'ai
rapporté en début d'après midi devant le
premier ministre et devant les autres
ministres qui étaient présents et puis
devant mes collègues bien évidemment
j'avais lance le sentiment de porter une
parole
justement une parole collective ce qui
ressort c'est que il ya une volonté de
notre part d'être associé un peu plus en
amont dans l'élaboration des textes de
loi alors ça peut paraître logique ça
peut paraître être la moindre des choses
c'est vrai que ça ne se passe pas comme
c'est rien avec les cabinets
ministériels plus de lien avec les
ministres on souhaite aussi voilà qu'il
y ait une collaboration politique pas
bien sûr technique mais avant tout
politique or souvent quelquefois elle
est technique elle arrive en fin de
parcours d'un texte et finit finalement
les échanges se font sur sur une virgule
alors qu'en fait ce que j'ai en tout cas
senti c'était plutôt une volonté d'être
associés pour à la fois bien sûr
l'élaboration du texte mais surtout pour
faire remonter aussi ce que nous nous
entendons tous les jours dans nos
circonscriptions parce que c'est ça qui
est important
il y a beaucoup de loi il y en avait
beaucoup avant là d'ailleurs reproché au
gouvernement précédent
nous en faisons de même beaucoup notre
rôle de parlementaire c'est bien sûr
d'élaborer de voter les lois mais c'est
aussi de regarder très précisément
comment elle fonctionne et comment elles
sont mises en pratique sur le terrain et
on le voit bien remonté envers un rêve
plus d'armements
c'est ça qui se passe on le voit sur des
lois qu'on était emblématique lors de la
précédente législature je parle par
exemple du grenelle de l'environnement
beaucoup parlé du grenelle de
l'environnement le problème c'est que
vous avez la moitié des articles qui ne
sont toujours pas parus par décret alors
c'est peut-être pas plus mal parce qu'il
avait sans doute des shows l'air il
avait de l'arctique à sion des lois
c'est l'éternel problème du foisonnement
des textes de loi et pour certaines
d'entre elles dès lors qu'il faut les
appliquer eh bien
l'administration a du mal à le faire
donc il faut sans doute que le politique
reprenne un peu le dessus et qu'on mette
un peu de bon sens aussi sur les textes
que nous votons et leur application sur
le terrain une petite question
subsidiaire annick lepetit est ce que le
président république doit recevoir à
l'elysée les députés socialistes il a
déjà commencé alors je vais le président
je ne les recevrai pas à l'ennemi il
avait dit cela parce que
nous étions sous l'ère de nicolas
sarkozy qui recevait c'est vrai à tout
va c'était déjà quasiment relaté dans la
presse avant même qu'il ait prononcé ses
premiers mots est d'ailleurs sous les
groupes oui mais en nous en tant qu une
certaine nous entendions à travers ce
qui a été relaté les propos de nicolas
sarkozy aux députés
nous nous ce que nous souhaitons aussi
bien sûr que nous souhaitons entendre le
président mais nous souhaitons aussi
pouvoir lui parler parce que il faut
qu'ils gardent ce lien avec je veux dire
d'une manière générale les corps
intermédiaires et particulièrement les
élus que nous sommes donc c'est ça que
nous nous demandons il a commencé la
commencer par voir une dizaine de
nouveaux députés parce que c'est vrai
risque rythmant la vie à plus de la
moitié dégonflées n'est qu'il a acquis
la sortie l'information oui alors fait
que moi je l' ai appris le lendemain
matin par justement des nouveaux députés
qui m'ont raconté donc leur leur rendez
vous je n'y étais pas non mais je je je
ne fais pas partie des nouveaux députés
mais je pense que tout ça va se faire
voilà il n'y a pas non plus une urgence
absolue et pour moi l'essentiel c'est
bien sûr éviter éviter parce que ça
arrive à tout le monde quel que soit le
niveau d'ailleurs ça évite aussi à un
certain nombre de présidents de conseils
généraux ou de mer éviter de se laisser
enfermer isolé et ça c'est fondamental
particulièrement quand on est à l'elysée
mais même aussi quand on est ministre de
n'importe quel ministère alors pendant
que le premier ministre s'est efforcé de
rassurer cette majorité tourmenté l'ailé
gauche du parti socialiste en a profité
pour présenter le même jour au sénat son
contre projet économique
un document de 30 pages à contre courant
de la politique du gouvernement
écoutez ce qu'en dit emmanuel maurel
vice président du conseil régional
d'ile-de-france et animateur du courant
maintenant la gauche il ya des millions
de français qui aujourd'hui se pose les
mêmes questions comment on fait pour
résorber le chômage de masse il ya plein
il ya des millions de gens qui se disent
et ce qui serait pas temps de mettre une
pause dans la politique de réduction des
déficits publics et de faire une relance
par la consommation notamment les bas
salaires les minimas sociaux
j'entends un mini ça ferme sa gueule ou
ça démissionne nous ça vous a pas
échappé on n'est pas au gouvernement des
militants socialistes et en tant que
militant socialiste on pense que notre
devoir c'est précisément d'ouvrir notre
gueule il ya un réel malaise des députés
de l'ailé gauche
une disent qu'ils ne se retrouvent plus
dans la politique de françois hollande
ils disent pas ça d'abord ils disent pas
tous la même chose il faudra quand même
qu'on définisse exactement ce qu'on
appelle la gauche parce que je pense que
c'est une parole un peu facile moi je
vais vous dire une chose je suis à
gauche je me sens à gauche et je n'ai
pas le sentiment que monsieur morel qui
n'est pas député et plus à gauche que
moi mais on peut prendre l'exemple de
marine elle marie noëlle lienemann et
sénatrices puisque elle a signé ce texte
faire une pause mais le problème c'est
que ça se passe pas comme ça ça me
rappelle d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
délits ou même de nos concitoyens même
quelquefois de journalistes qui pensent
que au bout des dix ans de droite qui
gouvernait notre pays
eh bien on pourrait mettre les compteurs
à zéro prendre une éponge effacer
l'ardoisé
comment se fait-il qu au bout de onze
mois vous n'ayez pas réussi à mettre en
place toutes les réformes à réduire le
chômage etc
c'est pas vrai ça c'est de la fiction
safari est quand même un certain claude
bartolone qui réclament un nouveau temps
du quinquennat avec des signes à
l'électorat de gauche ila veut dire ça
ne faisait pas quand même un peu contre
la rigueur
non je ne crois pas j'ai entendu j'ai lu
bien évidemment ce qu'a dit claude
bartelone je les ai entendus ce week end
puisqu'il s'est pas mal exprimé
sur des chaînes de télé au contraire il
a défendu la politique économique du
président de la république et du premier
ministre
alors après quantique quantis nouvelle
politique d'austérité elle est
nécessaire c'est pas on n'est pas dans
la politique d'austérité la politique
d'austérité c'est celle par exemple
proposé par françois fillon la que cette
semaine d'ailleurs je crois où il disait
qu'il faudrait que l'on soit payé 35
heures mais qu'on travaille 39 heures
ça c'est de la politique à une austérité
quand on est obligé de baisser les
retraites le le revenu quand on est
obligé de baisser les salaires
quand on est incapable d'assurer une
protection sociale là on rentre dans
l'austérité ce n'est pas notre cas nous
préservons non seulement les plus les
familles les plus modestes notamment sur
le plan de l'impôt mais aussi nous
assurons cette protection sociale c'est
vrai qu'on voit moins dans des pays je
pense notamment à des pays du sud de
l'europe où là l'austérité est déclarée
ce n'est pas le cas dans notre pays ce
n'est pas le cas dans notre es qu'on
peut quand même à ce que vous êtes
d'accord pour lâcher un peu de lest
quand toi il ya quand même des vendredis
après midi ce message des socialistes à
angela merkel pour desserrer un peu
l'étau pour qu'on desserre l'étau vous
êtes des cons ça c'est un autre nom mais
ça s'il s'agit de la politique d'angela
merkel et la politique europe est hérité
européenne qui s'est pas la même jory
jld des 3% de déficit
oui mais on n'est pas sur le même le
même créneau me semble-t-il si vous me
permettez deux secondes ce que proposait
ce qu'on a entendu dans votre sujet
marie noëlle lienemann et quelques
autres c'est le changement de politique
en france
en revanche moi je crois au contraire
qu'il faut soutenir la politique
présentée est faite par le président de
la république et par le premier ministre
parce que c'est aussi cette politique là
qui va permettre de faire entendre
davantage la voix de la france par
rapport à la politique européenne qui
est menée et de desserrer de commencer à
desserrer l'étau ou sur d'autres sujets
qui concernent par exemple la lutte
contre les paradis fiscaux
on voit bien que sur un certain nombre
de sujets qui ont été portés
par la france qui ont été portées par
françois hollande
petit à petit on commence à être entendu
bien sûr qu'il faut desserrer l'étau
vis-à-vis de l'allemagne des soeurs
qu'il faut peser sur angela merkel mais
nous pourrons peser vis-à-vis des loups
sur elle que si nous mêmes
j'ai envie de dire nous balayons devant
notre porte et balayer devant notre
porte c'est réduire les déficits qui ont
été quand même creusé de façon
incroyable ces dernières années et ça
peut paraître là aussi incroyable par la
droite elle-même
donc c'est pour ça que je me tourne vers
mais mes camarades quand ils se
définissent de la gauche veut dire
réduire la tête ce n'est pas une
politique de droite la preuve c'est que
la droite avant nous ne l'a pas fait al
ahly que tu vas passer au mardi mariage
pour tous clap de fin ou presque celles
épilogue d'un feuilleton parlementaire
qui durait depuis six mois le mariage
pour tous est adoptée en ce mardi par
les députés dans une ambiance que l'on a
qualifié d' électrique
résumé cette science qualifiait aussi
d'historique par jean baptiste daoulas
sortez moi ces excités de l'assemblée
les ennemis de la démocratie n'ont rien
à faire dans l'hémicycle des opposants
au mariage pour tous tente de déployer
une banderole en tribune
ils sont ceinturés est expulsé de
l'hémicycle un incident qui n'empêche
pas le vote du texte quelques minutes
plus tard pour 331 co2 125
standing-ovation sur les bancs de la
gauche
la droite elle a déjà déserté
l'hémicycle jusqu'au bout l'ambiance
aura été électrique à l'image des cent
trente six heures de débats consacrés au
texte par l'assemblée
noël mamère rappelle le déferlement
homophobes du mariage homosexuel qu'il
avait célébré à bègles en 2004 j'ai
encore dans l'oreille devant les grilles
devant les grilles de la mairie de
bègles ceux qui criaient les en
camp de concentration en face
l'opposition ne désarme pas une fois de
plus
hervé mariton met en garde le
gouvernement vous aurez sans doute la
majorité je vous demande de respect des
lois et fragile
votre loi est fragile nous saisirons le
conseil constitutionnel et chacun le
sait ici vous vous méfier du peuple
après le vote
christiane taubira veut mettre un terme
aux tensions homophobe des derniers
jours elle lance un appel aux jeunes
homosexuels en souffrance si vous êtes
pris de désespérance balayer tout cela
ce sont des paroles qui vont s'envoler
restez avec nous et garder la tête haute
vous n'avez rien à vous reprocher nous
le disons haut et clair à voix puissante
parce que comme disait nietzsche les
vérités tu celle que l'on tait
deviennent vénéneuse l'assemblée tourner
la page d'un feuilleton épique
tous les regards sont maintenant tournés
vers le conseil constitutionnel n'est
que petit vous êtes dit quoi au moment
du vote
ouf c'est terminé je me suis dit que
désormais tous les couples étaient égaux
ils ont pouvait
quel que soit quel que soit son couple
quel que soit son choix de vie décidé de
se marier de ne pas se marier de se
pacser de ne pas se pacser voilà c'est
c'était ça le fond de la demande c'était
ça le fond il est des députés
socialistes qui ont renoncé à
l'amendement pma procréation
médicalement assistée par ce que vous
avez donné la garantie que ce serait
dans un texte famille tout à fait ce que
vous pensez aujourd'hui que cette
promesse sera tenue ce texte n'est pas
la famille n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
de la le jeu me semblaient pour
l'instant non ce n'est pas à l'ordre du
jour mais en même temps tout à l'heure
je vous disais que ont légiféré beaucoup
donc un pion enfin on est là pour cinq
ans mais je pense que nous pourrions le
faire d'autant que vous croyez à ça
mouille et oui vous avez pourquoi je le
crois parce que quand vous avez comme
moi écouter les débats jour et nuit et
que vous avez entendu les arguments de
l'opposition ils ont persuadé tout le
monde que la pma était déjà dans ce
texte
alors tant qu'à faire on peut continuer
à en parler est vraiment faire en sorte
que dans un texte plus large nous
puissions mettre la pma en tout cas moi
je ne change pas d'avis par rapport à ce
que je disais il ya quelques mois ci
dans ce texte sur la famille il ya la
pma pour les couples homosexuels est ce
qu'il ne faut pas alors aller vers la
gpa la gestation pour autrui pour les
couples d'hommes je je je trouve je n'en
fais absolument pas un pendant je ne
comprends pas qu'on puisse comparer l'un
et l'autre ce n'est absolument pas la
reina permet d'avoir un enfant avec un
lien humain si c'est comme si vous vous
excusez moi je dis pas ça par rapport à
vous je mets c'est comme si vous me
disiez bah écoute et voilà les femmes
sont enceintes donc les hommes
aimeraient aussi être enceinte
c'est à peu près la même la même
comparaison donc je ne fais aucune
comparaison entre l'un et l'autre
mais vous avez raison ce débat n'a pas
eu lieu puisque il n'était pas la peine
a en tout cas n'était pas dans dans le
texte mais les discussions qui ont lieu
dans l'hémicycle
au delà de des sourires qu'on peut avoir
par rapport à a c'est vrai une
exagération une caricature qui s'est
produite suite notamment à des mensonges
nous devons de toute façon je pense
avoir un débat sur les questions de
famille ou pluriel parce que là aussi on
a entendu qu'on n'avait pas forcément la
même
appréciation la même vision de la
réalité qui est notre pays aujourd'hui
concernant l'évolution des familles en
un mot on a vu la droite saisir le
conseil constitutionnel vous redoutez
une censure du conseil constitutionnel
sur ce texte notamment sur les questions
d'adoption
non je ne redoute pas parce que
l'article 1 ça a déjà été dit par le
président du conseil constitutionnel il
y a plusieurs semaines maintenant qui
est l'article majeur de ce texte de loi
jeux pour tous il définit le mariage
pour tous et dans la constitution il
n'est pas écrit noir sur blanc qu'il
faut être hétérosexuel pour se marier
donc je n'ai aucun souci là-dessus après
il ya peut-être sur le plan de
l'écriture juridique dans un certain
nombre de codes puisqu'on nous avons
beaucoup de code qui régit notre notre
juridisme dans ce pays
oui peut-être ça se produira mais en
tout cas je pense qu'il ne faut avoir
aucune crainte sur la remise du mariage
et de l'adoption parce que on sait
parler d'eux et l'opposition avait
évidemment cette volonté-là
systématiquement mais en fait quand vous
regardez les textes ça va ensemble c'est
à dire en tout cas voilà la filiation et
dans le mariage dans le code civil
allez on passe au mercredi c'est
opération mains propres le gouvernement
abat ses cartes pour moraliser la vie
politique mesure d'interdiction des
activités de conseils pour prévenir les
conflits d'intérêts et puis après la
transparence imposée aux ministres les
parlementaires seront soumis à des
obligations ce qui ne va pas sans
susciter quelques réticences
aussi bien à droite qu'à gauche jean
baptiste des menaces les parlementaires
traîné des pieds mais le gouvernement
persiste le projet de moralisation
prévoit la publication de leur
patrimoine
outre les ministres et les
parlementaires les responsables
d'exécutifs locaux seront aussi
concernés une haute autorité
indépendante sera chargée de contrôler
les patrimoines les refus de déclaration
ou les mensonges seront punis les
sanctions pénales en cas de non
transmission de déclarations mensongères
seront lourdes 3 ans d'emprisonnement
45000 euros d'amendé et jusqu'à cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
damende pour les membres du gouvernement
restent à définir à quel point les
patrimoines des parlementaires seront
rendues publiques plutôt réticents les
députés ps sont prêts à négocier
nous sommes persuadés qu'il est possible
d'avoir un très large accord et
peut-être même si elle le veut bien
l'opposition sur ce texte à partir du
moment où on recule pas sur la
transparence c'est en même temps on
encadre la publicité parce que c'est pas
non plus un livre ouvert toutes les
informations pour tous les proches des
parlementaires à l'assemblée le sujet
dépasse les clivages politiques entre
transparence à tout prix et peur du
voyeurisme la publication des
déclarations de patrimoine n'apportera
rien du tout sauf satisfaire un certain
voyeurisme
si tu aimes démocratie du peep-show et
bien moi je peux aller m'expliquer
devant tous mes concitoyens sur mon
patrimoine au premier euro et leur
expliquer pourquoi je suis propriétaire
mon appartement parce que j'ai acheté il
ya quinze ans que je me suis endetté
rembourser mes dettes etc
sur le cumul avec d'autres activités
professionnelles le gouvernement a lâché
du lest il n'est plus question d'une
liste de métiers interdit pour les
parlementaires
ils devront simplement éviter de
conseiller ou de travailler pour une
entreprise dont l'activité est en lien
avec l'administration
enfin nouvelles règles les
parlementaires fonctionnaires ne seront
plus en détachement met en disponibilité
en clair leur carrière professionnelle
restera au point mort pendant leur
mandat alors la publication du
patrimoine reste un peu en travers de la
gorge de certains parlementaires ce que
vous allez le faire aisément
écoutez ça se fera dans un cadre je
pense que c'est ça qu'il faut faire et
c'est ça qui est demandé moi je suis
très content depuis une loi parce que
quand même j'observe depuis 11 mois
maintenant que nous n'avons pas voulu on
nous en avions discuté au mois de
juillet contrôler les frais de
fonctionnement que nous avons qu'on
appelle la rfm nous n'avons pas voulu
supprimer la réserve parlementaire
quand je dis supprimé en faire autre
chose que ce qu'elle est aujourd'hui
c'est à dire distribuer ou on à le
rendre transparent mais même c'est
l'idée même de cette réserve
parlementaire qui est quand même
curieuse je fais livre une petite
anecdote moi j'ai mis trois ans quand je
suis devenu député en 2002 avant de
savoir qu'il existait une réserve
parlementaire j'étais peut-être un peu
naïvement fois personnes étaient venues
de personnes venaient en parler puisque
chaque député n'avait absolument pas
envie de dire ce qu'il faisait de cette
enveloppe alors c'est vrai il ya eu
quelques modifications introduites par
par le président claude bartolone
mais c'est pas suffisant alors il s'est
pas suffisamment on peut pas à chaque
fois dire non ça c'est pas possible ça
c'est pas possible ça c'est pas possible
et il concerne avancé pour vous c'est ce
projet de loi est une et non parce que
je suis d'accord pour que ce soit dans
un cadre depuis 11 mois jeu il y avait
aussi une autre chose qu'on voyait
c'était un certain nombre de
nos collègues qui mettait sur leur blog
leur patrimoine
moi je n'ai pas entendu que le barcelone
de tirer la sonnette d'alarmé en dur
attention pourquoi certains le font est
ce que ça veut dire que regardez moi
j'ai rien à cacher sentiment d'être jeté
en pâture mais non non justement c'est
pour ça que vous parle des ya 11 mois
c'est pas vrai on est pas jeter en
pâture sas et c'est une fausse lecture
en plus la transparence de la vie
politique c'est toujours la gauche qu'il
l'a porté voilà et donc là on parle
c'est vrai plus spécifiquement pourquoi
de la publication du patrimoine des élus
parce que on a le sentiment est
particulièrement nous les parlementaires
qu'on est en train de fermer toutes les
portes de fermer les volets à double
tour je pense que c'est une personne
mauvaise a atteint pour la publication
vous êtes d'accord pour la publication
des patrimoines des députés ou mais tue
toute façon c'est dans la loi
alors moi j'ai l'un des amendements de
suppression des lois
oui eh bien écoutez s'est soumis à
l'avis du conseil visiblement c'est le
conseil d'état qui est qui voilà sa part
des encore une fois il doit y avoir des
règles moi je souhaite que la vie privée
soit préservé parce que c'est pas donné
oui à condition à condition qu'il y ait
un cadre mais de la même manière lorsque
nous parlons de nos patrimoines en
faisant une déclaration d'impôts
d'impôts et ben on remplit un formulaire
il ya un cadre on est assez à l'aise
c'est loin sur les conflits d'intérêts
le fait qu'on interdise juste l'agglo
cumul avec une fonction de conseil
nous consultons on pourrait aller plus
loin en reprenant certaines propositions
du rapport jospin qui vise aussi les
présidents de conseils généraux les
maires par exemple vous pouvez être élu
local et présidé une société
d'aménagement
vous pouvez les fonctionnaires donc non
c'est pas forcément le cumul des
fonctions c'est enfin oui c'est à dire
que les élus sont beaucoup dans des
conseils d'administration ont aussi ce
rôle qu'on ne connaît pas toujours et là
vous avez
c'est vrai la possibilité alors après
bien évidemment à chacun d'avoir cette
discipline et cette rigueur pour ne pas
se laisser aller aux délits d'initiés ou
conflits d'intérêts mais il faut quand
même le réglementer un peu plus on verra
sans doute des amendements en ce sens
oui on suivra avec intérêt mercredi
encore journée à marquer d'une pierre
noire pour les rapports entre le
gouvernement et les élus communistes au
sénat ces derniers avaient réussi à
faire passer un texte instaurant une
amnistie pour des délits commis lors de
mouvements sociaux
mais le ministre alain vidalis se dit en
ce mercredi opposée à cette amnistie est
dans la foulée le texte est rejeté en
commission des lois à l'assemblée colère
des députés les sénateurs communistes
radical aucun article ayant été adopté
il n'y a pas lieu de soumettre
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi au
vote de la commission un rejet qui
entérine la division sur ce texte d'
amnistie au sein même de la gauche
cette proposition de loi communiste
avait pourtant été adopté au sénat par
une très courte majorité le 27 février
dernier
ce texte vise à amnistier les délits
commis lors des mouvements sociaux
depuis 2007
mais ce mercredi matin le gouvernement
clarifie sa position par la voix de son
ministre des relations avec le parlement
la position du gouvernement dans ce
débat sera non nous ne sommes pas
favorables à cette amnistie n'y a aucune
autre ça a été la position du président
de la république depuis l'origine
une décision qui pourrait faire monter
d'un cran la tension entre le ps et les
élus communistes on arrive à l'assemblée
nationale et le ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement dit dans la
presse on va écouter excusez-nous non on
votera ou empêchera seppois de passer
au jeu juste trop je trouve qu entre les
deux eh bien les oreilles du
gouvernement c'est un peu trop tendue du
côté du medef
nathalie kosciusko morizet il voit une
totale improvisation de la part du
gouvernement ils se rendent compte que
ça tombe mal
et alors bon dans la plus grande
confusion après l'avoir plus ou moins
soutenue au sénat finalement le
gouvernement déclare qu'il ne soutiendra
pas à l'assemblée nationale mais tout ça
on le voit c'est c'est l'affolement
c'est la précipitation c'est la
précipitation pour un gouvernement qui
ne sait pas quoi faire en matière
économique et sociale qui n'est pas au
rendez vous des vrais problèmes des
français
les communistes n'ont pas dit leur
dernier mot ils pourront de nouveau
défendre leur texte le 16 mai prochain
dans l'hémicycle alors le 16 mai
prochain donc niche parlementaire
communiste vous voterez pour ou contre
ce texte contre vous suivrai l'avis du
gouvernement je suivrai l'avis de la
commission le reste du gouvernement
s'est tendue du côté du medef dit
marie-george buffet il ya eu un
changement parce que visiblement les
sénateurs communistes avaient l'aval de
christiane taubira maintenant maintenant
le gouvernement est contre je ne sens
pas que les sénateurs communistes
avaient la même c'est ce qu'ils ont les
zidane taubira en effet c'est vrai que
le gouvernement a dit sagesse puisqu'il
y avait une majorité pourrait donc le
gouvernement n'avait sans doute pas
envie de se retrouver mais minoritaire
quand gouvernement dit sagesse c'est
qu'il ne prend pas part à cette
discussion
je comprends en même temps que chez les
sénateurs socialistes coq qui ont
beaucoup travaillé sur le texte se sont
dit puisqu'on a énormément retravailler
ses titres allons-y
parce que cette loi d' amnistie en tant
que tel
n'a pas vraiment de sens alors il ya
quelques mesures est d'ailleurs alain
vidalies gelé entendu l'a10 a notamment
sur ceux qui ont refusé de se soumettre
aux tests adn pour être dans les
fichiers bon ça pourra se retrouver dans
d'autres lois et notamment des lois
pénales qui vont qui vont arriver
bientôt à l'assemblée nationale
mais en tant que tel donner le signe que
bien évidemment sous prétexte que vous
êtes dans un conflit extrêmement dur
socialement vous pouvez faire n'importe
quoi et tout casser
c'est un signe que le gouvernement n'a
pas souhaité donné et que la commission
des lois parce qu'on parle peu de la
commission des lois quand même que la
commission des lois n'a pas voulu non
plus donner
donc oui pour sur quelques mesures
spécifiques dans d'autres véhicules
législatifs mais pas oui sur ceux sur
cette proposition de loi alors au sénat
le front de gauche reste furieux après
le recours au vote bloqué pour faire
adopter la loi sur la sécurisation de
l'emploi
les sénateurs communistes mais aussi les
sénateurs de droite ont donc obtenu du
gouvernement le report au 15 mai de
l'adoption définitive de ce texte
joachim robe tourner enfin la page
mariage et ceux consacrés à l'emploi
c'était l'espoir de françois hollande
aujourd'hui plus que jamais le
rassemblement du pays doit se faire sur
l'emploi le redressement la confiance le
gouvernement espérait donc un vote
définitif jeudi de la loi sur l'emploi
mais c'était sans compter sur la fronde
des sénateurs ulcéré par le recours un
vote bloqué pour écourter les débats
communiste en tête ils ont décidé de
reporter le scrutin au 14 mai quand on
faire un vote bloqué s'cusez moi je n'ai
pas respecté le travail parlementaire
c'est décidé brutalement qu'il n'y a
plus de débat quelle que soit la
position qu'on peut avoir sur les
différents textes il faut que le
parlement soit respectée il faut que le
débat parlementaire aille à son terme de
semaines de délai a priori rien de grave
sauf que le gouvernement espérait faire
passer cette loi avant les défilés
syndicaux du 1er mai et la manifestation
du front de gauche le 5 mai je comprends
que le gouvernement soit embarrassé
il s'est mis lui-même d'un difficultés
avec la volonté de passer en force au
sénat en écoutant pas suffisamment les
débats et en prenant pas suffisamment le
temps des discussions ump udi crc
écologistes quatre groupes ont voté ce
report
les socialistes connaissait la position
des communistes mais regrette que des
écologistes et rejoint la révolte
moi je trouve qu'il ya une incohérence
absolue dans cette façon fonctionner
parce que c'est pas le débat n'était pas
au général sur le vote bloqué mais là
concrètement sur une loi qui doit vivre
entre en application qui est la
traduction d'un accord
l'assemblée nationale a voté mercredi
soir la dernière version du texte avant
son retour au sénat dans deux semaines
alors le texte reviendra donc au sénat
le 14 mai s'il n'y a pas une faute du
gouvernement a quand même avoir recours
à ces votes bloqués il aurait pu prendre
le temps de discuter tous les
amendements déposés par les touristes
je remarque de la faute du gouvernement
moi je vais faire partie
des parlementaires qui défendent le
gouvernement nous avons eu le temps de
le discuter à l'assemblée nationale
après il ya des questions de calendrier
mais tout ça se négocie aussi avec le
sénat et notamment le président du sénat
on n'entend pas d'ailleurs et donc à un
moment donné je trouve que lorsqu'on
déclare dans tous les groupes d'ailleurs
que l'emploi est prioritaire alors il
faut le manifester par des actes
concrets
et puisqu'on en parlais tout à l'heure
excusez moi de ce petit clin d'oeil mais
enfin on demande la mystique pour des
faits ou des délits commis dans le cadre
professionnel
mais en même temps on ne veut pas
visiblement légiférer un accord avec des
amendements des amendements qui ont eu
des avancées ici à l'assemblée que le
sénat peut tout à fait reprendre
on ne veut pas délibéré un accord
partenarial un accord c'est vrai
historique n'a pas signé certes la cgt
et fo ne l'ont pas signé mais la cgt et
fo ont participé aux négociations et la
cgt et fo signent des accords dans les
entreprises en ce moment à tour de bras
donc pourquoi ne veut-elle pas signer un
accord national pour justement enclenché
ce fameux dialogue social que nous
demandons depuis des années et des
années dans notre pays alors mercredi
toujours les députés votent la création
d'une commission d' enquête sur la
sphère cahuzac ou plutôt sur les actions
entreprises par le gouvernement pour
connaître la vérité après les
révélations de mediapart
aucun des six groupes parlementaires ne
s'est opposé à la création de cette
commission
jérémy hartmann qui est contre la
majorité requise n'est pas atteinte en
conséquence la demande de création d'une
commission d'enquêté est adopté une
commission denquête voté à l'unanimité
l'image n'est pas fréquente mais de
gauche comme de droite les députés
s'accordent sur l'utilité de ce travail
de contrôle du gouvernement
d'abord réclamé par le groupe udi la
rumeur est le poison de la démocratie
aussi la proposition de résolution
tendant à la création d'une commission
denquête que le groupe eut dit vous
propose de voter a pour seul objectif de
substituer à la rumeur la vérité car
après les aveux de jérôme cahuzac début
avril
c'est l'ensemble du gouvernement qui a
été pointée du doigt par l'opposition
que savaient les échos
tif et depuis quand que savaient les
services de renseignement y at il une
instrumentalisation de l'administration
fiscale
pour répondre à ces questions il reste à
définir clairement le périmètre d'action
de cette commission
elle ne pourra pas enquêté sur la sphère
cahuzac en tant que tel car elle n'est
pas autorisée à empiéter sur l'action de
la justice qui instruit déjà ce dossier
sa seule mission consistera en fait à
pointer les éventuels dysfonctionnements
du gouvernement et des services de
l'état dans la gestion de cette affaire
trois ministères sont dans la ligne de
mire
celui de l'économie et des finances dont
dépend des jérôme cahuzac celui de
l'intérieur dont les services ont été
chargés d'authentifier l'enregistrement
téléphonique ont dévoilé par mediapart
enfin celui de la justice non pas pour
enquêter sur les juges mais pour
s'intéresser à l'action de la ministre
christiane taubira et de son cabinet en
revanche le président de la république
ne sera pas concerné mais les 30 députés
membres de la commission espère
auditionné certains collaborateurs de
françois hollande notamment son
directeur adjoint de cabinet ils
auraient pu avoir été mise au courant
dès le 15 décembre de l'existence des
comptes suisses de jérôme cahuzac
alors les socialistes ont signé des deux
mains pour cette commission denquête
jean marc ayrault c'était s'était
prononcé pour dans l'hémicycle on s'en
souvient est-ce qu'il faut que ces
auditions soit ouverte à la presse
au risque de s'enliser un petit peu dans
cette affaire peut-être sur le plan
médiatique puisque nous sommes dans la
transparence
soyons le jusqu'au bout moi je vais vous
dire une chose je préfère qu'il y ait
des commissions à travail en tout cas
parlementaire quels qu'ils soient qui
soit ouvert à la presse plutôt que le
lendemain d'avoir dans le journal ou
sur 1 ou dans vos commentaires et bien
d'aider des phrases prononcées of dit
anonyme enfin moi tous les jours je suis
frappé par sa maman je préfère
finalement que à la limite la presse
assistent à nos travaux au moins comme
ça c'est clair en tout cas pour ce qui
est des socialistes nous n'avons
strictement rien à cacher nous avons dès
le début des clus des à proposer cette
commission denquête guy vous remarquerez
que ce n'était pas le cas lors du
précédent précédent précédente
législature où nous avions demandé à
certains nombres de commission denquête
que ce soit sur l' affaire karachi ou
sur d'autres sur les sondages de
l'elysée
nous tenons absolument au principe qui
est de la liberté de la presse et de
l'indépendance de la justice
transparence c'est le mot de cette
émission
oui c'est le mot de la semaine aller et
on passe au jeudi
quand une mauvaise blague virale affaire
d'état tout a commencé par une vidéo
diffusée sur le site d' atlantico.fr des
images volées des locaux du syndicat de
la magistrature dans lesquelles on voit
je cite un mur des cons des dizaines de
personnalités la plupart de droite sont
moqués alors cette affaire suscite un
tollé à droite jeudi au sénat à
christiane taubira lac à la garde des
sceaux annonce qu'elle a saisi le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature en
écoute j'ai saisi le conseil supérieur
de la magistrature pour lui demander
s'il peut apprécier
s'il y a maintenant à la déontologie
ce syndicat a pris des risques sur
l'ensemble du corps de la magistrature
et notamment sur ses propres membres
à en juger par les menaces de récusation
sur les procédures en cours
c'est dommageable à l'ensemble du corps
j'espère que nous en sortirons parce que
ce qui est important c'est
qu'effectivement notre magistrature
retrouve sa noblesse que nous puissions
la débarrasser du soupçon qui pèse sur
son impartialité et que leur relation
soit éclaircie entre le corps de la
magistrature et l'exécutif elle a eu
raison
christiane taubira de stopper l incendie
il fallait mettre un terme rapidement à
cette polémique
oui tout à fait je trouve qu'elle est
vraiment là totalement dans son rôle de
garde des sceaux elle est d'ailleurs
habituellement est là elle a dit sans
dramatiser sans polémiquer sans en
rajouter parce que je trouve que voilà
je bien évidemment que c'est par surtout
quand on est garde des sceaux voir ça à
la légère
enfin en même temps j'ai entendu
notamment monsieur hortefeux figure sur
celui je pense qu'il doit être un des
premiers
je ne veux pas rajouter le roi mais en
tout cas il doit être un des premiers à
figurer sur sur le mur donc il porte
plainte
oui il il est dans son droit de porter
plainte donc celles et ceux qui
souhaitent porter plainte le fond après
que ça devienne une affaire d'état voilà
il faut trouver la bonne mesure je
trouve que christiane taubira est un
syndicat comme un autre est-ce qu'il
peut y avoir comme ça une politisation a
ouverte à fischer écoutez moi j'aimerais
aller voir ce qui se passe dans les
bureaux des comités d'entreprise de
syndicats d'entreprises publiques par
exemple et de voir ce qui est affiché
sur les murs voilà sauf que ça ne nous
regarde pas et c'est pas chaque voilà
c'est un bureau c'est un lieu privé
alors c'est vrai que là l'erreur sans
doute c'est de faire entrer des
journalistes puisque visiblement et
c'est le cas pour atlantico qu'un film
est discrètement mais qu'à filmer quand
même et qu'il l'a mis sur son site
voilà là il faut une responsabilité pour
ce qu'ils veulent c'est choqué parce que
finalement sens inverse
vous verriez un mur il ya aussi
la gauche si j'essaye c'est peu comme
quoi vous voyez ils ont compris qu'on
était là depuis peu de temps et
peut-être que dans deux ans on sera plus
nombreux j'en sais rien mais je crois
qu'elle comparaître je crois oui va
disparaître mais je crois qu'il faut
prendre les choses avec un peu plus de
de sérénité et de pas dramatiser surtout
parce que alors à ce moment là on est
plus crédible dans la hiérarchisation
des prix des priorités encore une fois
je soutiens la garde des sceaux dans ce
qu'elle a dit dans l'hémicycle c'était
responsable c'était sérieux
mais voilà je pense que ça ne vaut pas
non plus une politique
une polémique qui dure depuis deux jours
le petit cette émission est terminé
merci beaucoup d'erreurs participé il ya
plus de siéger plus pendant quinze jours
peut-être prenez ou quelques vacances
parlementaires
assez peu parce que j'ai pas eu le temps
mais on travaille sur un texte logement
qui arrive dès la rentrée par le monde
d'accord entre la relance et
l'investissement ça arrive
quant à nous et bien on se retrouve
seulement dans trois semaines puisque il
n'ya pas d'hémicycle et donc pas de
parlement hebdo a dans les deux semaines
qui viennent merci beaucoup merci des
leviers de revoir
entre 1903